Your components need to show different things depending on conditions.
React handles this with plain Java script.
Start with if statements, a function component can return different JSX based on a prop.
IsPact is true, return the item with a checkmark, isPact is false, return it without, two
separate return statements.
You can also return null.
If isPact is true, return null, the component renders nothing.
It disappears from the output.
But returning null is rare.
Usually, you conditionally include or exclude the component from the parent instead.
For inline conditions, use the ternary operator.
IsPact questionmark, name plus checkmark colon name, one expression, two outcomes.
Please keep your JSX compact, but don't nest them, deeply nested ternaries are hard
to read.
There's an even shorter pattern, logical end, isPact ampersand ampersand checkmark.
If isPact is true, render the checkmark, if false, render nothing.
Watch out for a common trap.
If the left side is zero, react renders the number zero, not nothing.
Use a Boolean condition, not a number.
You can also assign JSX to a variable, let item content equals name.
Then if isPact, reassign it to name plus checkmark, return the variable in your JSX.
This variable approach is the most flexible.
You can mix in any logic if else if switch before your return statement.
Let's recap, use if and return for completely different JSX.
Use ternary for inline either or choices.
Use logical and for conditionally including an element.
Use variables when the logic gets complex.
All of this is just JavaScript, no special react syntax, that's the point.
Next up, rendering lists.